[Music]
it's Michelle from Lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD and lover of bath
bombs bath bombs are tons of fun and
they recently turned 30 years old so I
thought I'd make a video talking about
the science behind bath bombs have you
ever wondered how a bath bomb works
what's in it and why does it fit this is
the video for you if you like the sort
of video click the thumbs up subscribe
to my channel and hit the notification
bell if you need to buy a bathroom you
probably think of lush and that's for a
really good reason bath bombs were
invented in 1989 by one of lucious co
founders Moe Constantine she wanted to
introduce luxurious ingredients to the
already pretty awesome bath time
experience she was inspired by
alka-seltzer tablets a fizzing hangover
cure and the first bath bomb also came
in tablet form soon the BlackBerry bath
bomb emerged and this was shaped like a
literal bomb luscious aesthetic became
more stripped back and with the
discovery of 3d printing we get bath
bombs and tons of different shapes so
what exactly is in a bath bomb there are
two components that make a bath bomb
fears an acid and a carbonate base for
example in lucious bath bombs there
citric acid which is found in citrus
fruit but usually made synthetically and
sodium bicarbonate or baking soda to
make a pretty and smell good there are
also pigments and fragrances there are
also sometimes other ingredients added
to make your skin feel nice like oils
and butters all the ingredients get
mixed together and then you put it into
a mold
press the two halves of the mold
together not too hard
and then wait 24 hours then you can take
the mold apart and you have your bath
bomb the fact that the acid in the base
of solid are really important in making
the bath bomb if you know the volcano
experiment with vinegar and baking soda
you'll know what happens when the acid
and carbonate base are wet
if fizzes straightaway that's because
the acetic acid in the vinegar is
ionized that means that the hydronium
ions in the acid can collide with the
hydrogen carbonate ions in the base to
produce carbon dioxide gas which we see
as fizzy bubbles but in the bath bomb
the citric acid is uh nyah knives in
intact
until water comes along and frees the
ions they're stuck in place and they
can't react when we add water then they
can mix at a microscopic level and
produce gas the fizzing means that the
bath bomb disperses faster and combined
with the heat from your bath water this
helps the fragrance fill the air this is
also why you should keep your bath bombs
in a dry place so probably not just in
the open in the bathroom moisture in the
air can make the acid in the base react
prematurely and so you've run out of
carbon dioxide by the time you put it in
your bath so you might be wondering
isn't baking soda bad for your skin
it's high pH doesn't that disturb your
skin and make it easier for bad bacteria
to get a foothold
well the fizzing reaction is actually
also a neutralization reaction that
means that we have our high pH baking
soda reacting with a low pH acid and
together they combine to form a mixture
that has an intermediate pH since the
basic bath bomb was invented there's
been a few other extra cool inventions
as well that go a bit beyond your basic
bath on for example lush failed a
patient in 2014 for a bath bomb with
distinct layers there are also jelly
bombs which contains sodium alginate and
these dissolve in your bath water to
form lumps of jelly which slowly
dissolve a bit later so that you don't
have glob stuck to your skin I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please
like it and subscribe to my channel
leave me a comment letting me know what
else you want me to talk about you can
also follow me on Instagram and
got my blog for more beauty science see
you next time